We are coming to the part of the Quixote,
the core of part one in which sort of Vantis makes a display of narrative
mastery by combining the sequential structure of the Ci Valerie Romance whose
form he's parodying with the multiple story design of collections of Novell lay,
the long short story favored by Italians from Boccaccio to bundle.
How can these two Java's,
uh,
B,
merged a mixed
Cervantes achieves it by taking his protagonist away from the center of the
story while still engaging him in the own folding and resolution of the
intercalated tales involving Gardenia Fernando or they are.
And Lucinda,
we will get to that
today and in the next class.
But first I want to begin by talking about the role that memory place in
narrative and the development of characters.
In the last class we saw how interrupted stories being told by characters led to
the revelation of other stories not being told or being told or obliquely.
In all of those cases,
memory is the key element.
Don Quixote.
It makes up the generic g Valerie novel,
Generic Chivalry Romance Drawing from his recollections of the Chivalric Nova.
A romances that,
that he has read in the past.
In the episodes in the Sierra Morena.
There are three moments,
uh,
when memory,
plays a crucial role.
The first is when Cardenio speaks about how painful memory,
the memory of his betrayal by Lucinda and Fernando is,
and how he would like to evoke it,
if only to make him,
uh,
have the strength of mind to commit suicide.
He says in page two,
25,
Oh,
memory thou mortal enemy of my repulse.
Why does thou represent to me now the incomparable beauty of that my adored
enemy,
where he not better cruel memory to put me in mind off unrepresented to my
imagination what she did then the move by.
So Flager Flager an injury,
I may strive seaside,
do not revenge it,
at least to put an end to my life.
The agonizing recollection of those events,
of the betrayal,
uh,
constitutes the defining story of Cardenio and the source of his madness.
It is not just what others did to him,
but what he failed to do,
a decisive moment.
He's cowardice as he refers to it twice.
He says that he was a coward twice.
The second instance when memory plays a role is one Gardanio says that he
vaguely remembers the fracas with Don Quixote.
When denied interrupted his narrative,
the episode is like a hole in his memory.
This is an example of server anthesis,
uh,
psychological sophistication,
that car.
Then you can only remember the fight.
We don't get healthy as if it had been a dream but cannot recall what provoked
it.
And I quote from page two 45 in your translation,
got a venue here upon remembered as if it had been a dream the coral he had with
donkey hot there,
which he related to the company but could not recollect when it arose.
Uncle Carl,
then your story has a gaping hole,
a crack at the climax that is contained within another crack Don Quixote's
interruption.
It is like this car left by a deep wound.
This lapse is a clear symptom of trauma we would say today cause Cardinia story
is full of hope of gaps and discontinuities.
The third instance when memory,
uh,
is highlighted,
is when Doterra,
that's Princess Mikko me Kona for gets her name.
Uh,
she plays that role when telling the story about the bogus story of her life in
page,
uh,
to uh,
55.
Um,
let's see you,
I can find it.
He says she's allowed to start to,
to start her story and she says in the first place,
you must know gentlemen that my name is he or she stopped short having,
forgot the name.
The priest has got given her but he presently helped her out for,
he knew what,
uh,
she stopped at and said,
we just don't wonder.
Madonna so forth
says she would make up the story,
uh,
basing it on her recollection of reading romances of chivalry.
This by the way,
is an inconsistency either in Sylvana versus uh,
a case or a Dodo.
Pay Us own recollections or,
uh,
when she told her her life or how her life was,
she said that one of her entertainment's was reading most of the devout
literature.
She didn't mention anything then about reading romances of chivalry,
but she does now.
So she would make up the story,
basing it on her recollection of reading romances of chivalry,
but the name was none of her invention but the priests.
So she quickly forgets it and it has to be prompted,
uh,
since as we commented,
her story is a translation of her current predicament into the discourse of the
romances.
Her for getting her name is also indicative of her traumatized self.
She has to drop assumed other roles after she was abandoned by don't Fernando,
which is the traumatic event in her life.
Her sense of identity is frail and in the process of being remade
now connected to all of this and perhaps the overarching memory lapse of the
mall is the loss of Santos,
his ass or Dapl as the translation calls him.
There is no name by the way,
in the,
for the ass in the,
in the Spanish origin.
But I know that in this translation on the others,
they call him dapple because I suppose of his color.
So,
uh,
remember that the,
this,
the theft of the,
of the,
uh,
Sanchez as is left out of the first edition,
and Cervantes hastily restored it in the second printing a few months later.
Memory is not just a repository of recollections and stories from the past.
It is that which structures the self in the present and the archive when's
narratives issue flawed and misshapen.
No longer a true reflection of what happened,
but regulatory over true about a character's state as he or she talks.
No.
So it is a truth about now about the present that may be full of holes,
a misrepresentations about the past.
It is nevertheless the repository of stories about the past.
So it is in that interplay between that floor recollection and the present that
the stories are told is what I'm driving at.
The representation of all of this,
of this,
uh,
interplay of memory and narrative is the overall network of interrelated,
intertwined stories that take place or are told in the Sierra Morina unresolved.
At one Palo Meccas in after Don Quixote's battle of the wineskins about which we
will speak into in,
uh,
in the next class.
Now,
Cervantes was very much aware of the complexities of that construct,
that network of stories we read at the beginning of Chapter 28 and I have a
handout for you to take a home,
uh,
which is the text that I'm going to read in Spanish.
And on the back of it,
uh,
various translations of it,
various extent translations of it,
um,
that I have a collected,
you're going to follow,
uh,
the Spanish,
on the,
on the Spanish side of the,
uh,
the handout and it says no solo.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
um,
we read it at the beginning of chapter 28 after we have heard.
Got to Daniel's tail in two installments.
Uh,
we have these remarkable self referential mark admonition on the part of the
narrator,
not solo ladol Sutra,
the suit that I see it better than La Storia see know that have quinto CIP
solely of day.
Yeah.
Game [inaudible] my Storia [inaudible] yes.
Palo Elo when Taqiyya [inaudible].
Now this is,
uh,
I regret to say Jarvis,
that translation that we are using this year.
Parents this down to quote,
enjoy the suites of his donkey hold as true story,
but also the stories and episodes of it which are in some sort of or less
policing,
artificial and true done.
The history itself,
which resuming the resuming the broken thread of the narration relates that you
can see his bare it down by smallest version with some inundations of my own.
You'll have it on the back,
your read on the smallest,
which is the last one,
uh,
in this hour age in so much in need of enjoying agreeable entertainment's,
not only of his donkey hold as true and delightful adventures,
but also of the intervening episodes,
which are no less real art,
full and delicious than the main story itself.
The twisted real than rabble thread of which is continued.
Thus Joses to curate was ready to offer some consolation to go to Daniel and so
forth and so on.
You can see how much,
uh,
Jarvis left out.
I want to call attention not just to what the text says,
but to the interruption itself,
which is a speech act that performs the function of interrupting in this
narratives.
A speech act is an act that a speaker performs when making an utterance
justice.
The breeze is about to reply to Gardenia.
He is prevented in smaller version.
Hindered in Jarvis is version by Donald J US voice,
which will provide part of the missing information in Cardinia was account that
can be no comforting of Cardenio yet interruptions rarely promote comforting
the to the words.
Cervantes used to refer to the buildup or spooling up of a narrative,
uh,
of narratives.
Trans brings this out.
They are drawn from spinning,
leaning thread [inaudible] as Palo and are reasonably reasonably well translated
by smaller us.
Twisted,
real and rattled.
But in the original they have,
at least for me,
perhaps it go Spanish is my native language.
The more violent or literal infection.
In other words,
twisted real,
unraveled are common English terms.
The WHO's metaphoric origin has now faded in Spanish.
The words used by said Vantis applied art allegorically to narrative are
shockingly fresh and evoke more directly the physical actions they describe.
The last three Yara is to rake out the excess fibers from the thread.
Daughter Sarah is to twist together many strengths in order to make a string or
thread.
And as spatter is to twist two sticks,
we've together to weave strings together as if as it's done in a smaller scale
with uh,
the needles in knitting when you go like this with the two needles.
So the two sticks are being a spar as Spanda,
the cross marriages Lucinda with Gardenia,
although she had been married to don for Brando and the Latte,
I don't know Fernando,
although she had been in Cardinia care,
replicate the positioning and actioning on action of the two sticks use for us
bar,
if you understand what I mean.
In short,
the relation among the stories including the main plot is predicated on blunt
cuts and criss crossings,
not on smooth transitions.
These are made possible by traumatic interruptions,
which jostled a memory of the tellers and drive them to reveal other stories
behind the one they tell and also make them disclose their inner thoughts,
rounding out their characters.
But in addition,
the whole network of stories,
which is like a quilt to continue this,
a metaphor having to do with cloth
is itself a superb display.
This play of narrative skill and of variety,
which is one of the aims of renaissance art.
But the question will always remain in spite of what the narrator says about the
relationship of all of these stories to the main story of Don Quixote and
century.
I'm sketching an answer here today,
but I must inform you and as you will learn in the prologue of part two,
Cervantes was criticized for including all of these stories.
And in the sequel he was careful.
He was careful to integrate them,
uh,
do integrate stories more seamlessly into the main narrative.
Uh,
he didn't include a story like the novel of the curious in pertinent about which
will be speaking in the next class.
Uh,
uh,
whose relationship to the main story,
is a debatable or questionable.
And we will,
we will talk about in the next class.
Now in the last class I focused,
uh,
we will talk about it in the next class.
Did I say the last in the next class?
Um,
in the last class I focus on the Fernando.
Remember when I talk about them,
I your ass go and they say when dawn and that whole background let us
concentrate today on Durrell and Gardenia
got a venue,
Edward Dudley who's name I put there in case it doesn't,
I don't make it clear,
writes in his superb essay,
the wild man goes baroque.
He writes the following and we need to be glossing some quotes from Dudley's
essay.
This wild man has got to Daniel,
the soul brother of Don Quixote.
Unlike him,
a victim of madness.
They're meeting in the Sierra Morina occurs in an atmosphere of unspoken
attractions and donkey hot.
They already mad,
is driven further into the shadowed wilderness of his insanity.
His subsequent imitation of Cardenio madness is the high point of his lunacy
unquote.
He adopted,
he is referring to the episode that I quoted earlier about the meeting of
Kardinia and Don Quixote when the night seems to remember having seen Cardenio
earlier.
Now the between the two is that Gardenia is a poet in the Petrarchan a vein or
gutsiness cause he last saw Wayne lag resource Tomo.
So there are parallelisms we don't get hold of.
But there also,
uh,
differences.
Dot.
Lee goes on to give a context to the figure of the wild man.
He says the approach to a wild man hidden in a threatening wilderness is an
archetypal pattern familiar in world folklore and one utilized by artists again
and again on quote even alludes to a modern work like Joseph Conrad's heart of
darkness,
which as you know,
is from 1900 the famous novel.
So the story of finding a one on,
in the,
in the wilderness is something that is a,
it's a folkloric,
a story.
He eat.
Dot.
Recites he goes and wolves as a kin to Cardinia in his moments of madness.
I mean,
these figures assume the,
uh,
the,
the role of,
of,
uh,
of uh,
he,
uh,
goats and,
of Wolf's,
uh,
two images suggest that suggest respectively the problems of sex and violence
that hunted the 17th century.
I would say that hunted all centuries.
But I mean,
he knows because he has studied stories in the 17th century.
Dudley claims that go cardinals problem is that he cannot talk effectively,
that he cannot communicate by means of the spoken word unquote and adds that
clinically got Carolinians.
Condition has been diagnosed as a case of Xolair anthropy Xo on therapy animal
man man becoming like an animal.
That's what the relationship between don't Fernando on Cardinia,
uh,
Dudley,
sees uh,
a homosexual pattern.
He suggests that the relationship between Cardinia and Fernando shows some
mutual affection,
uh,
that,
in a way,
uh,
anticipate the relationship between the two protagonists of the novel of the
curious impertinent that we'll be discussing in the next class.
That is that the relationship between these two men is mediated by,
by Lucinda.
But that actually it is a real,
it's,
it is a homosexual relationship between the two of them.
Um,
more inline with what I had been saying about interruptions.
Dudley says that in asking Cardinia to tell his story called Donkey Quixote
anticipates the 20th century analyst who begins the cure by having the patient
tell his story and it is in the story that the cause of the madness is found
justice.
It is by means of donkey holders intervention that the cure is initiated.
But as he proceeds,
it becomes apparent that the real reason it is,
is that he's autistic.
I once above all not to be challenges.
He's in his debut,
his interpretation of the events.
I will say that it's not that he's autistic,
but that he has been traumatized and that trauma has caused something akin to
autism,
but it is not,
uh,
autism.
And then he says that [inaudible] plays an important role because not of there
appears before.
Cardenio and he has,
he admires her beauty,
but there's not lost after her.
And that in that process,
the cardinals a cure,
uh,
has to be gone.
And this is a typically a renaissance,
a idea of a cure by provoked by,
uh,
the contemplation of beauty.
And that this is the role that,
uh,
Dorothea place in this,
in the cure of,
uh,
Carlene.
Carl Daniels character's a character flaws.
And his intermittent bouts of madness are perhaps the reason,
uh,
the reasons why Shakespeare found Cardinia compelling and wrote a play about
him.
A play that was lost by the way,
it is known that Shakespeare wrote a play based on current venue.
Remember that Quixote appeared in translation in 1611.
So Shakespeare had time and he did the read Don Quixote.
And to read this story and to write a play on,
uh,
about the,
based on this character,
well,
unfortunately it was lost.
Uh,
but one,
one is left to wonder,
what did Shakespeare find compelling in the character of Kardinia?
Uh,
I,
I would say that of course there is a,
a,
a ham that like tendency to hesitation in,
uh,
in,
in Cardinia,
uh,
that may have,
that Shakespeare may have found a attractive,
uh,
of course,
could you close that window so that we don't hear this,
a gentleman outside,
um,
laughing at each other's jokes.
You could also yell out and tell him to shut up.
But
no,
I think this is pretty good.
So,
uh,
one,
one interesting topic for a paper would be to speculate why Shakespeare wrote a
play on,
on,
on Gardenia,
along the lines of what I have suggested here.
But you can come up with your own ideas.
And in fact,
uh,
a professor from Harvard,
Stephen Greenblatt,
uh,
I read in the paper not long ago actually,
he'd been an expert on Shakespeare road,
uh,
play,
based on,
on,
on Gardenia,
uh,
literature.
Professors are often tempted to the line and to write literature.
The results are not always a very felicitous,
but I haven't seen greenbelts play,
so I'm not judging it.
Now,
that'll tell us a story as we know.
And so in the last class,
the appear,
you said used by Fernando who is dead,
Mary's Lucinda,
is there some kind of culpability in Doterra?
Did she not also consider at the crucial moment what a good match Fernando would
be?
Wasn't she trapped by the fact that if she resisted,
no one would believe that she had not allow for Nando in her room?
Like Cardenio,
she hesitates at the moment of truth.
But unlike Cardenio,
she makes a decision and takes action.
Harris is not a submissive surrender is a calculated,
a surrender.
When Fernando Disappears,
uh,
g goes in search of him,
but then discovers that the marriage to leucine that may not be final and that
she may have a chance to force him to make good on his promise.
Remember that Fernando,
uh,
she discovers a,
has been going hunting,
uh,
after he,
left her completely oblivious to her,
got a venue or on the other hand is pushing land in most cowardly.
And Lucinda cannot bring herself to suicide at the crucial moment as she
intended to do.
Don't tell on the other hand is not passive.
She invents herself like Don Haughty and like him racist herself in social
class.
Ultimately because she does Mary Don Fernando,
we will see sue.
We will soon see the role she plays in bringing a resolution to the conflicts
and prepare the way for donkey holders return to his village.
Now,
little tell story is as,
as compelling as Gardenias,
but she is more composed and determined to obtain some sort of restitution.
Her situation is complicated by the fact that her father has done Fernando's
vassal and could hardly,
she could hardly be the one to seek revenge or compensation according to custom.
But by law she had recourse to both,
uh,
to revenge and compensation.
But with the help,
uh,
usually with the help of a man legislation in the wake of the Catholic kings
program to reign in the aristocracy made it a crime for noble men to take
advantage of peasant women,
Gardenia,
or being a man and an aristocrat like Don Fernando and the Duke offers to stand
up for her clearly because it is also in his interest.
He makes the promise in strict accordance to law and costume.
He says that he will challenge Fernando to a duel using the word [inaudible],
which is a,
an old Spanish word,
uh,
for,
and which was part of a Spanish legislation in the Middle Ages.
But that had been,
uh,
banned by,
legislation in the 16th century.
That is by the 16th century.
A noble woman were not allowed to a duel with each other over,
uh,
an issue.
But there was a lot of debate because of course the aristocracy wanted to retain
that,
right,
which went back to visit gothic times when uh,
uh,
when a nobleman,
took care of this,
uh,
issues,
by,
uh,
by fighting each other
now that he's reassured of leucine does virgin or condition and this is crucial
and the questionable legality of her marriage to Fernando.
Cardinia is encouraged to take action and he in and he invokes what he believes
to be his right.
[inaudible]
story is briefly interrupted by Gardenia who cannot refrain from saying
something when he hears about his own misfortunes from her point of view,
this is the rest of his own story,
which he himself did not know.
And when he reveals a lot out there and he's identity parts of her story that
she did not know fall into place,
the interruptions are like the seams between the pieces of a large puzzle for
Cardinia.
The crucial piece is the scene of the wedding of Lucinda and Don Fernando,
which had appeared prolifically in the foundry story that he blurted out when
donkey Quixote interrupted him.
The business about Queen Manasi Ma and the surgeon having had an affair.
Remember that psychotic version that he had in his mind about that the flowering
of Lucinda,
but now he ended up,
they are begin to discern potential happy ending to their misfortunes and and at
the intersection of their stories when they discover,
when they hear each other's stories,
the deleted motive,
the gap in the story concerns the legality of Fernando's and leucine does
marriage and her retaining her virginity.
It is that Chason fraught with violence and erased from Cardenas memory that
needs to be filled in the melodramatic and conclusive scene at one Palo
[inaudible] in Gardenia expresses his desire for restitution using legal terms
to describe the damage inflicted on him and leucine.
Down page two 45 it says,
there is still room for us to hope that heaven will restore to each of us our
own since it is not yet 80 and eight it nor past recovery.
This is a crucial words.
The original reads BM podemos have [inaudible],
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] and Susannah in Wa he Nosha and [inaudible].
The last part is a notario formula using contracts involving the assessment of
properties and their resale value when returned to the original owner.
I think too that Todavia is times to sell.
It remains whole in its integrity is a euphemism to say that Lucinda is still a
virgin as those this HR on don is in vocation of heaven,
means that once rescued from the wilderness,
the law,
both human and divine will again take effect and their story will have a happy
ending once they have left that wild place of the Sierra Morina,
uh,
law will again take effect,
human and divine law.
Now,
Doterra is ogled in one of the most explicity and sophisticated erotic scenes in
the cohort that I hope you remember.
Like Cardenio little tear is first a voice heard by the barber,
the priest and Caledonia who laments her fate.
She is sound before she's a visible body and she will be,
she will become a very visible body.
Indeed central.
Remember has left to fetching donkey haughty and [inaudible].
The priest and the barber discover the beautiful Doterra in a shady spot washing
her feet in a brook.
She's disguised as a farmhand,
but soon by spreading her gorgeous blonde hair,
she reveals herself as a very beautiful young woman.
Her beautiful harmonious body is seen in stages by the men who spying on her
without being seen.
The pleasure of voyeurism is not just seen but not being seen.
Doterra is the object of a converging gazes that process her by parts first and
insistently and fetishistic Lee her feet.
You have all,
I'm sure even in your youthful,
uh,
heard about foot fetishes.
When I was a graduate student at Yale,
there was a foot kisser in the library.
A guy who,
who,
uh,
came,
if a woman was sitting at one of these desks that have a front like this,
but nothing underneath,
he would come up and take her shoe off,
kiss her foot and runaway.
And,
um,
this,
I don't know if he was ever caught,
but there was a warning about a foot kisser and sterling memorial library.
I tell you the stories that you remember,
or,
uh,
of,
Donald Tests,
uh,
feet.
They're desiring gazes cut the body in parts.
If Violin at violent act of possession,
Dorothea who has an ensemble and bodies.
Perfect beauty is consumed by the men looking at her in pieces.
She is a version of Diana in Greek mythology and also Sinai in the book of
Daniel Women who were observed naked by voyeuristic men in Roman mythology.
Diana was the goddess of the hunt being associated with wild animals and
woodland and also of the moon.
Uh,
along her main attributes.
Diana was an emblem of chastity oak groves where especially sacred to her if her
figure in art appears accompanied by a deer.
This is because Diana was the patroness of hunting.
The deer may also offer a covert reference to the myth of Actaeon Actaeon who
saw her bathing naked.
Deanna transformed that down into a stag and set his own hunting dogs to tear
him apart.
This is the,
uh,
Susannah or Shoshana.
Lily is one of the additions to the book of Daniel,
uh,
accepted by the Catholic and eastern Orthodox churches.
As the story goes,
that beautiful Hebrew wife is falsely accused by literals wires.
Uh,
she bathes in her garden,
having sent her attendance away to lusty elders,
secretly observed the lovely Susannah when she makes her way back to her house.
They are cost her threatening to claim that she was meeting a young man in the
garden unless she agrees to have sex with them.
She refuses to be black males and he's arrested and about to be put to death for
promiscuity.
When a young man named Daniel interrupts the proceedings and after,
uh,
and he finally gets the,
the two,
uh,
old men to contradict each other when he cross examines them and they are,
they are executed.
And,
uh,
so,
virtue who triumphs.
But the crucial image here is that,
uh,
Susana being observed ogled by the two men,
the two old men and of acting on looking at the naked a Beijing.
Um,
so this is what is behind this beautiful,
uh,
seen,
that I,
uh,
point you to inpatient to a 30 of your,
translation.
It is,
uh,
too long for me to read completely.
But just remember that they come,
these are Gardenia,
the priest.
And the Barber's Andrew is not within the three men are looking at her.
And uh,
uh,
they drew near,
so silently,
uh,
that he remember,
they think he's a,
he did not hear them,
nor was he intent upon anything but washing his feet,
which were,
which were such that they seem to be two pieces of pure crystal growing among
the other pedals of the brook.
They stood in admiration of the whiteness and beauty of the feet,
which did not sustained,
which did not seem to them to be made for breaking clots or following the plow
as an owner's dressed might have persuaded them.
They were,
I'm finding there were not perceived.
The priest who went foremost made signs to be able to,
to,
to crouch low or hide themselves behind some of the rocks,
thereabouts,
which they accordingly date on,
stood up,
serving attentively,
attentively that the,
what the youth was doing.
And then he goes on to describe,
uh,
how,
um,
uh,
the doterra washes her,
her feed,
how her hands are beautifully,
uh,
White,
and,
uh,
on her hair cascades down to the point that it,
it,
uh,
makes a polo envious,
I'm going to say in,
in,
in a minute.
Uh,
uh,
eventually,
they,
they discover,
uh,
to her who they are on the scene and schools.
Um,
this is,
uh,
this is a scene that could be a renaissance painting.
And in fact,
Cervantes was well acquainted with Italian renaissance painting for us,
you know,
having read in the case books,
Atlantis spent,
uh,
a good deal of time in Italy and professor Frederick Data Mass Frederick,
they added or of Eurasia,
Chicago has written two books about the impression that Italian art made on
Cervantes and the,
uh,
imprint that these impressions left in his work.
And this is obviously one of those,
uh,
why,
why is there a version of the classical and Biblical myth?
It is,
it is a renaissance move.
Uh,
as I said,
where on the part of Cervantes,
this background enhances the figure.
He didn't hazards to figure to have her be a version of a classical myths.
It adds to her beauty and to the prestige of the creation.
And also it shows that art can make a depressant or a present scene be like a
classical myth.
And this is crucial to understand why the scene is so much.
Uh,
like those renaissance paintings don't test beauty shines through her course and
cross dressing a uncross gendering dress.
In fact,
it is enhanced by it.
The contrast,
the HMIS lead anticipation.
You begin to see what you think is a male.
And suddenly as the person these robes,
it begins to show a female fish features and the graduate revelation of body
parts.
Uh,
these are all we erotic moves,
a gradual,
uh,
revelation of the body.
Transvestism is ramping in the Sierra Morina as you may have noticed.
First the breeze dresses as a princess.
Then the barber puts on the dress when the priest becomes a little squeamish.
Here we have characters in drag ogling characters in drag.
The Barbara dressed as a woman,
looks upon the beautiful daughter who is dressed like a man.
What does it all mean?
It suggests that in the disorder,
in the disordered world over the woods of this sexuality is so primal that it
empty seats,
gender distinctions.
It is a form of generalized desire.
Transvestism dusters rampant in the Sierra Morina.
Um,
when the priest,
uh,
addresses dot Altair later,
he simply tells her that she can claim to be whatever she wants to be man or
woman,
meaning that she can use feminine or masculine endings and pronounce a Spanish
allows for gender distinctions in the speaker.
Dear Madame or dear sir or whatever your pleasure,
whatever you pleased to be.
This is what the translation says.
Uh,
that is this Bob Lavalle.
This,
uh,
area in the wilderness is a place so far outside the law,
the genders have yet to be defined and it is even pre grammatical in the sense
that it's before these endings can determine or express gender.
This is suggested by the locals.
Avenal remember I've discussed the locals Aminos for the pleasant place before.
Like the one we found Rosie Nantais was aroused by the mayors after the Marcella
[inaudible] episode.
The locals are Manos,
Eh,
which is the perfect side for Amaryllis exchange,
enhances [inaudible] appeal.
There are light and shade patterns.
There's water,
uh,
that reflects on this torch.
It was,
uh,
a place,
according to translation.
It was a place,
uh,
through which the run a little smooth stream,
cool unpleasantly shaded by some Brocks and neighboring trees.
Uh,
the waters of the book's full of reflections and refractions that are,
uh,
that repeat on this thought.
Her image increase her erotic appeal first or feeding the water looked like
pieces of glass as transparent as the water itself.
Later,
her hands acquired of whiteness of snow.
Her golden hair would provoke the MV of a Polos of Apolo.
These are symmetries and reflections concurrent with the larger ones concerning
the various characters and plot stamp as the strengths and trying to establish
here the relationship between these locals or Menos on what takes place in it
and the overall pattern of these stories.
All of these episodes are made of correlations between the plot,
the characters,
the settings,
and the scenes.
Though doterra is a relative opposite of Lucinda,
who is arrested aristocratic but has little money.
Dorothea is rich but not uninstall.
Cratic Doterra is also kind of Daniel's counterpart,
loss as she is in the solitudes of the woods fleeing this guy's from her fate,
symmetries and order.
Contrast with the disorder caused by the best.
Tillandsia Amorosa,
the Amaryllis pettiness that donkey halt,
the donkey health Quixote spoke about in the speech of the Golden Age that
imagined golden age.
And this locals,
our manuals are shown to be a shown to be artifices that conceal desire in
assemblance of order,
but ultimately cannot contain,
contain it and violence and Soules.
So I want you to have clear in your mind the what is at stake here in this local
some manuals and it is a violent,
uh,
not overtly violent,
but it's violent,
a procession of Galatia by the gaze of these men.
Uh,
uh,
and the relationship that all of this has with the overall pattern of the
stories that I am analyzing here.
[inaudible] hurts her feet when she tries to flee barefoot and over the rocky
ground.
She's physically wounded
as she was when she lost her virginity to Fernando.
Uh,
and,
uh,
she was almost wounded again when she was,
the servant tried to rape her and she,
he threw her,
she threw him over a cliff.
We don't know if he's dead,
uh,
and later when her employer tried to seduce her,
these are dangerous woods.
Um,
so the,
the story of Kardinia Lucinia Fernando and Dorothea is told from at least two
perspectives mucker Daniels under hotels.
It is also total in various moments and with the attendant interruptions that
are,
have been mentioning,
all is assembled under the umbrella of the main story to get don Quixote out of
the Sierra Morena and back home.
The stories are all United by the theme of love,
but considered at many different levels.
Now we move on to the,
uh,
hilarious invention of Princess Mikami corner by the priest.
And this whole episode,
uh,
conceived to try to get Don Quixote,
back home by inventing a fictional devalued romance in which we'll take him back
to his village because to,
to reach the,
the,
uh,
kingdom,
of comicon.
He will have to according to the story to tell him go about his village.
So
don't test story as prince's Mikami Kona is a translation of a real situation.
Javier Arrow put his name there so they can be,
you know,
he's a good friend of mine with whom I agree and disagree.
Always respectfully.
He summarizes the situation.
Dus brings me Colby corner of the Kingdom of [inaudible] is the daughter of
magician,
magician king,
the nok Rio,
the wise man and the Queen Hermia by means of his science.
The king finds out that someday the princess would be an orphan or a terrible
giant panda.
Philando.
They our first [inaudible] whom we have met before,
so called big o because he's queens to frighten people will assert the kingdom.
The king further prophesied that only one night could defeat the giant,
the famous Spaniard [inaudible] dilemma.
That's the synopsis that have you had,
gives us,
there is substance,
there is substance to characters invented by characters.
That is [inaudible] vista and business Mikami corner antenataly.
Otherwise all characters invented by,
by the priest and performed by Doterra.
So this,
these characters,
uh,
invented by characters or acquire substance within the fiction.
They are Metta fictional characters.
Now,
a panda Filando Purnaa philanders name suggests lost.
He is a Pan Philanderer who says what is a philanderer?
Philander is a man who has many love affairs.
So Penn generalized Philanderer,
actually if you go back to the Greek is lover of man,
but Pan Philanderer.
He is a pan lover.
The persistent recidivist insistent,
prolific lover.
This is [inaudible] giant.
Yeah,
the name Nico me Kona is at first glance funny,
it sounds funny,
but it has several restaurants.
It has to do with monkeys.
She is from call me,
come the Kingdom of monkeys.
Mono is the most common word for monkey in Spanish,
but Mikko means monkey in a more general way.
What do monkeys do?
Monkey see,
monkey do.
Monkey is imitate humans in a comical way,
only form not substance.
So they are like parodies of us.
If you've been to the zoo,
just stand in front of the of the monkey cage and you'll see that they make
there seem to be making fun of us by imitating us indirectly.
Uh,
humorously,
the issue of me,
Macy's is brought up here by Cervantes.
Me.
Macy's was the renaissance doctrine of imitation,
imitation of the classics,
the mutation of the classic models to come closer to the imitation of reality.
Me,
Macy's has to do with the rep breaths and you can hear his etymological
relatives to mimic the mine and memetic.
So,
and one can hear even a faint echo of me,
Macy's in Mikko me Kona,
but,
but Mico Macona here means that she is from the Kingdom of monkeys of a kingdom
of representation,
a kingdom of parodies.
This is what this means.
[inaudible] is here.
Also do see nails rival because Santo wants very badly for his master to marry
the princess so that he can get his kingdom gs.
A copy of Gucci now,
or an echo of Lucy now,
who's,
uh,
remember the Dulcinea and,
and uh,
uh,
Dorothea Ryan,
now they don't see now who now appears is the one that Sangio makes up in his
lie about his visit to her.
Remember the kind of brawny smelly.
Do see Neha,
who gives him a piece of cheese,
he gets it up next to her and he says,
oh,
Geez,
Paul.
And uh,
she smells and okay,
Hill does this.
How could you smell?
You were probably married yourself on San Jose.
Yeah,
it could be because I smelled like that sometimes.
Uh,
it was all very funny.
But why essential tell in the light?
Because he's Saint Joe once Don Quixote to marry the princess.
So he's trying to bring goose in there down to make her look bad.
But Don Quixote is deterred.
This says,
no,
no.
Uh,
you must have this,
uh,
this wrong.
Uh,
now,
so remember that Donald Tan Lucinia rhyme,
which underscores the relationship that they have at these very heavy now meta
fiction or level to see these.
This is the mentor of fictional level,
what the characters are creating,
what the priest is creating,
what McCormick,
what Dota is creating by representing,
by performing the story on what sanctuary is creating with his life.
Now we know now what is behind the live central light.
Remember all of these stories always have something behind them or always
telling another story.
The story being told here is that central once don Quixote to marry the
princess,
become econ and not to marry the scenario.
So he's trying to make her look bad.
There is another rhyming echo here that reveals to what extent,
uh,
the story that Dorothea is telling.
Is it a version of her own a predicament?
Bon Daffy,
Lando Fair Nando Banda Filando Fair Nando.
So you'll see there is a connection here and,
uh,
oral clinician connection between the two,
characters.
So,
uh,
this is,
this character who's lost four,
uh,
and that,
read or we'll claim,
uh,
later.
Uh,
stance is an allegory of lust itself.
Now,
at one point,
nearly everybody here is in this guys.
Some men have been in drag playing various roles.
Even sanctuary is playing the role of the squire of a bogus night.
Aaron,
the deep Western about this episode,
we just made a fictional levels.
He said about the theatricality of life.
This is where the Quixote leads us again to ask questions that are pertinent and
relevant to our lives.
Is leaving,
is leaving the playing of roles?
Are we characters in somebody else's fiction as these characters are here?
And if so,
for instance,
are we bound by ethics?
If we are just mere characters in somebody is fiction.
There are stories within stories creating the infinitely receding sequence that
I spoke about before.
We can lose track of the real end of the self in such a construct as I told you
a little boys used to do when they went to the barber shop.
And so all of these repeated images of themselves who,
where are you?
Who are you?
I have heard that under hypnosis we cannot be made to do anything that goes
against our sense of values,
against our morals.
However,
in dreams we do transgress principles and engage in this wish fulfillment
fantasies in which we transgress principles.
Freud's interpretation of dreams published in 1900 suggests and has suggested
for the 20th century and Anna,
uh,
an analog for literature and for this levels of friction.
One of those literature,
Stan,
among all of these states of mind in his own madness,
don't in his own dream.
Don Quixote will go on with this madness.
We will continue to be mad and his dream in the stories that they make cup,
however,
Mikami Kona and Santo do tell their deeper desires and apprehensions.
The subconscious force is stronger than their will to lie.
They want to lie and they tell the truth.
Uh,
uh,
indirectly.
Uh,
these are the issues that this complex,
this complex of stories.
Uh,
uh,
so just
no,
let me talk for comic relief as we come to the end about,
and since we were talking about values and principles about an obscene passage
in the Quixote
[inaudible] Javiera claims that the rabble,
the tale that the barber burrows from the innkeeper's wife means her genitals
and that the obscene reference to it leads to an identification of panda Filando
with the fallows,
hence donkey Haltech cuts off a,
follows the symbol of lost.
I think that it is mostly just a dirty joke on the part of Cervantes who is
having fun with a keen reader that he imagines good.
Understand the obscenity behind this.
The innkeeper's wife says,
and I'm going to read it first in Spanish,
but Ami,
some tea water.
You remember that she did.
They borrow that oxes tales that they have that she had where she kept her comb
so that the barber,
the priests and the barber can make a beard and look different.
But I [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Merito Boriso swallows [inaudible]
then we went our cola
by my faith,
this is Jarvis.
You shall use my tail no longer for a beer.
Give me my tail again for my husband's thing is dust up and down.
That it is a shame.
I mean the comb,
I used to stick in my good tail
and rental reits,
I think,
uh,
overinterpreting with your friend.
This is then the extended joke.
The Barber has taken away the innkeeper's wife tail into which the innkeeper
used to put his thing.
This is just translation.
Little also referred to us as comb.
When the Barbara gave it back to her,
she complained that it,
it is completely spoiled that it has lost his hair and that it will not serve
any longer for what her husband used.
It have read or continues as we are going to show immediately,
but I will spare you his proofs.
Tail rubber or cola means the loans both male and female genitals and so the
artist cool and beard has a similar meaning.
Cervantes has created with this multiplicity of obscure meanings.
I don't think they were your secure at Constellation,
the constellation of sexual images which are finally conveyed on the giant
himself.
I can't go there with her yet.
I think that the joke is very clear.
I don't think it's very obscure.
It's very clear and it's very funny.
I don't see how it can be extended to the giant however,
but one wonders,
Wine Cervantes included this obscene joke in the text.
As I said,
I think he's just having fun with a reader who could pick it up.
Now the story's sub stories and interruptions in relation to memory.
Bring to mind.
Going back to the beginning of my lecture today,
bring to mind the issue of Cervantes says oversights,
particularly the one about sanctuary,
stolen donkey.
What does it mean?
Perhaps that creation is the floor product of memory.
One critic has suggested,
as I believe I said before,
that's Advantis included errors in decky halted purposely.
I doubt it because he did try desperately to fix them within months.
But the errors are consistent with certain characteristics of the Quixote,
just improvisation and the faculty and the faulty improvisation on the faulty or
creative nature of memory by making mistakes we create deviating from model for
I'm saying is that the mistakes of memory as we've seen in the story is told by
the characters are creative.
What is the value of the subtexts to use that word that we found beneath the
story's being told like the one about,
um,
uh,
doterra's predicament and the one that,
Cardinia was really telling to learn that sometimes,
perhaps all the time as story is the deflected version of another.
So what,
so the pleasure lies in the gradual discovery of the story within the story as
with the entire Quixote.
All this has to do with the nature of narrative and with the nature of
literature,
the multilayer discourse,
who's just is precisely it's hidden meanings that surface in odd ways.
Why didn't sit around this embed these stories about [inaudible] are up there
and don't Fernando within the overall story of a guilty,
did he,
did he think that they or the main story could not stand on their own?
The stories are reflections of the main story as we have seen both in their
themes and by their inner structures,
the characters create other characters.
The stories are broken up on started again,
many characters display some sort of madness.
They are like mirror images of Don Quixote.
Mostly I believe Cervantes was searching for a way to create a new Java.
He did not know yet which that would allow for this admixture the sequential
plot of the Valerie Grumman's,
the multistory,
uh,
kind of book produced by,
the Italians and new Java that would allow for,
for this admixture of main story.
And dependent or lateral stories.
And he did create it.
He created,
uh,
what came to be known as the novel by doing this now beyond literature,
the most significant idea behind this intermingling and the errors is to pass
it.
That memory is the self,
that the self is memory with all its flaws and its holes and its gaps.
Remember that the novel,
the Quixote begins with a willful act of forgetting that village in [inaudible]
whose name that narrator does not want to remember.